tu fuis tu te défiles tube horst reste
un axe arrête de dire que tu es un
c'est pas parce que tu es la voix qui
portent que c'est ton chien les au moins
officiellement qu'ils portent
moi aussi je peux qu'aller est beaucoup
plus fort que toi tu es tu es là depuis
une heure à m'expliquer ce qui est bien
ce qui est mal
tu as toujours fait les bons réflexes
les bonnes réactions les bonnes opinions
ces chats à chaque fois que tu ouvre la
bouche on entend l'évangile l'évangile
selon max tu n'es pas l'évangile tu dit
beaucoup de conneries depuis que je te
connais savez ça fait 35 ans je suis pas
d'accord avec tout ce que tu racontes je
fais semblant parce que j'ai pas envie
de l'engueuler 1
mais je suis pas d'accord et plus ça va
plus ça empire
tu vieillis pas tu ta grave regarde mais
revient de ton appartement mais rien qui
dépasse c'est fois c'est vide c'est
triste dans les médias n'y a aucune vie
là-dedans puis tu t'écoutes non mais tu
t'écoutes tu dis pas les femmes
tu dis les bonnes femmes qu'est ce que
tu connais aux bonnes femmes t'ai jamais
été foutu d'en garder une taille
téléphone mais tu réponds pas parce que
t'es pas à la disposition du premier
connards qui t'appelle pourquoi le
rendez vous avec toi faut envoyer un
courriel tu écoute de la musique mais tu
as les vinyles écouter de la musique sur
un ordinateur non non on en ramène au
sacrilège
tu n'aime que les chanteurs morts
ta collection c'est un cimetière trévé
brel brassens ferré ferrat mozart palau
ti nougaro je déteste loup garou cher
non moi j'aime les chanteurs vivant
parce que t'es pas ça j'aime le foot
parce que c'est pas ça j'aime la télé
parce que tu aimes passera j'aime tout
ce qu du ps et je déteste tout ce que tu
aimes parce que ça fait 35 ans que tu
m'emmènes
max tu m'emmerdes tu me fais chier
schepp hutin
tu veux du café oui je veux bien oui